Can you get into the knee dive position buddy?
Thank you, man.
So, bring your toes close.
The thing that I'd like you to notice is that we have her toes beneath her foot,...
...we have her foot on the edge of the pool,...
...and that Cally's hugging her ears as tight as she can with her arms.
And most importantly, keeping her head down,...
...looking at her...
What are you looking at, Cally?
Belly button.
So, what we're gonna do to help support her...
...is we're gonna ask her to lean forward as close as she can,...
...attempting to or trying to touch the water with the tip of her fingers...
...because you wanna have the fingers go into the water first.
As you can see, I'm supporting her belly button right here...
...just to help her as she slides into the water.